Hey. Hi. Welcome, everybody. I'd like to start our session on
advancing precision approaches to head and neck cancer. I'm Barbara Bertness.
I'm a medical oncologist at Yale School of Medicine.
So just as a brief introduction to head and neck squamous cell carcinoma, this is
a relatively common cancer, the seventh most common cancer
globally. We estimate about 890,000 new
cases a year, so it's just under 5% of new cancer
diagnoses and almost half a million deaths every
year. So again, just under 5% of global cancer deaths.
The risk factors for head and neck cancer are age, nutritional status,
alcohol exposure, exposure to tobacco and other oral
carcinogens, and I think an open question there is whether or not
vape is going to turn out to be a driver of head and neck cancer,
germline DNA repair abnormalities, and human
papillomavirus.
An interesting thing about a cancer with these diverse
causes is that,
across these diverse etiologies, there are actually
commonalities in what signaling pathways are disrupted.
So we see loss of p53 function, whether it arises through
mutation, as is common in HPV-independent head and neck
cancer, or because a viral oncoprotein is leading to
degradation of p53, as is the case in
HPV-associated cancers, CDKN2A mutation and
amplification, PIK3CA mutation or amplification.
Then there's this observation that patients who are adult
survivors of Fanconi anemia, whether or not they've been
transplanted, have an extraordinarily high rate of head and
neck cancers.
And a parallel observation that something like a quarter of sporadic
HPV-negative head and neck cancer also displays mutation within that
pathway. And so one of the things I think
people in the field are doing is asking whether or not these
insights point to shared therapeutic vulnerabilities across the different
types of head and neck cancer.
We do naturally categorize these cancers as
HPV-related or HPV independent, and you'll
see that that's
somewhat the approach we've taken to this session as well.
And the reason for this is not only the different etiologic
basis, but also a different natural history.
So HPV-associated cancer tends to be somewhat less
aggressive and is much more treatment responsive.
And these data here come from a national study of chemoradiation
where the overall survival for patients with oropharynx cancer that was
HPV-related as opposed to HPV unrelated, was very
dramatically different, as you can see here.
We focus a lot on treatment resistance, partly because the majority
of patients with head and neck cancer present with a locally advanced
cancer. And so they present with a stage of
disease that we attempt to cure, whether that's with surgery, radiation,
chemoradiation, or some mix of those, with or without
immunotherapy. And for HPV-related cancers, about 80% are
cured. For HPV unrelated, about 50% are cured.
And as you'll be hearing from the next speaker, some HPV-related cancers
probably can be cured with much less intensive therapy than we currently give.
We've known for a long time that combination chemotherapy is active but not
curative. Immunotherapy now provides a long-term
survival benefit for a proportion of patients who
have recurrent metastatic disease and a proportion of patients who are
resectable, but many patients don't derive substantial benefit
from immunotherapy as we're currently giving it.
And if we look at the genomic signature of these cancers, loss of
tumor suppressor function is the predominant event in
HPV-negative cancer, and this has slowed advances in targeted
treatment.
To sum up what I see as sort of our clinical and translational research
goals in head and neck cancer, firstly, I think to appropriately define risk and
treatment sensitivity so we can tailor the treatments that we've already
shown lead to survival advantages in terms of intensity and
duration. To extend the utility of immunotherapy with
rational combinations, and those might or might not be rational combinations
with other immunotherapy agents.
To add targeted treatment that's appropriate to the molecular profile of the
subset of head and neck cancer that you're dealing with.
I think that's likely to differ by HPV status, as I'll show you a little bit.
And then if we are successful in incorporating more targeted
therapies, address the adaptive resistance that we know will emerge.
So this is the agenda we've put together to try to address this.
First, I'll be asking,
how can we make better progress with precision approaches to
HPV-independent cancer?
Then, Del Yarbrough, a surgeon scientist who's chair of
otolaryngology at Chapel Hill, will talk about subtypes of
HPV-initiated head and neck cancer.
What are the implications for de-escalation and precision therapy?
And then Dr. Ari Rosenberg, who's an associate medical
oncologist, associate professor at the University of Chicago, will address
minimal residual disease and treatment optimization in head and neck cancer.
So I'll dive right into my talk, Precision Approaches to
HPV-Independent Head and Neck Cancer. Here are my disclosures.
And so we do know a lot about the molecular profile of these
cancers. But what I've done with the color coding here is try to indicate
how little of that we actually use in treatment decision-making.
So we can make treatment decisions based on PD-L1 and tumor
mutation burden. We have a sort of global approach to
HPV-negative head and neck cancer that derives from the observation about
overexpression of epidermal growth factor receptor.
And then we don't do very much, with other things that we know to be very
important, such as p53 mutations, CDKN2A
mutation or amplification, hypoxia, and an immune
microenvironment that's rich in cancer-associated fibroblasts and
myeloid-derived cells.So let's start with PD-L1
expression. This is from the KEYNOTE-048 trial, which was a study
that looked at incorporating pembrolizumab into treatment of patients in the
first line for recurrent metastatic head neck cancer,
and compared either pembrolizumab monotherapy or pembrolizumab
plus chemo to an older standard of chemotherapy plus the
EGFR-targeted antibody cetuximab.
And as you can see here,
the hazard ratio as you move from the total population to the population
of cancers with PD-L1 expression to those with
PD-L1-rich expression, the hazard ratio improves from
0.72 to 0.63 for pembrolizumab plus
chemotherapy, and the five-year survival crosses the
20% mark for the first time in this disease.
We went back and looked about what about the PD-L1 low patients, and
so here for pembrolizumab alone and here for pembrolizumab plus chemotherapy,
you can see there is an advantage to the use of pembrolizumab in those with CPS
1 to 19. But for those who express really essentially no
PD-L1, it's deleterious to use pembrolizumab alone,
and it's no better to use pembrolizumab plus chemo.
So I think we're all using PD-L1 expression in daily practice in head neck
cancer. What about tumor mutation burden?
Because we link that to sensitivity to immunotherapy.
So, if you look at the top panel here, this is from the
TCGA, and if you focus in the second bar here, the gray
ones are the ones that are HPV negative.
Whether those patients are smokers or non-smokers, whatever the anatomic
site of the head neck cancer is, you can see across the board, they tend to have an
elevation in non-synonymous mutations.
And Robert Haddad used this information to look at
response to pembrolizumab in an early trial in treatment refractory
disease, and you can see for both HPV negative and HPV positive,
there's at least a numeric improvement in response rate for those patients with a
higher non-synonymous mutation burden.
And there is, in fact, FDA approval for using PD-1 inhibition
in TMB high cancers. So those two things, I think, are firmly
established in practice.
We looked to see whether or not there could be a tie-in to p53,
so I did this work with Erika Golemis and the people at Caris
Biosciences, looking at 1,000 HPV negative head neck
cancers. And
we looked at the p53 mutations by whether they were disruptive, by
whether or not they led to a loss of function or a gain of function, whether or
not they impacted truncation or the DNA binding domain.
And sort of across the board, you can see that either p53 mutation,
as long as it wasn't a gain-of-function mutation, or
CDKN2A abnormalities led to a higher
TMB. Co-occurrence of the two mutations
led to an even higher TMB, and then we used TMB of 15
or higher sort of as a cut point for might be good
candidates for immunotherapy. And here, across the board, whether you look at the
blue lines, which are p53, the green, which are CDKN2A,
or the red, which are co-mutation, you can see that the mutations did
drive a higher incidence of high TMB, with the exception of
the gain-of-function p53 mutations.
Well, what about EGFR? This has been recognized since the
1990s when Jenny Grandis reported overexpression of
EGFR and TGF-alpha in head neck cancer relative to adjacent
normal tissue.
This is protein overexpression, ligand overexpression, and
protein amplification. Mutation of the receptor is
not common in head neck cancer, in contrast to some forms of lung cancer.
And this has led to molecular therapy with cetuximab since the early
2000s.
We understand from correlative studies and some of the
randomized trials, either with cetuximab or with EGFR-directed
TKIs, that resistance can arise from
abnormalities in downstream signaling, very analogous to colon
cancer, with the one difference that this has never made it into clinical practice
in head neck cancer, which is somewhat regrettable.
But loss of PTEN, mutation in PIK3CA, mutation in RAS are
associated with resistance. And then we see, either at
baseline or in the adaptive response to EGFR inhibition,
upregulation of HER3, MET, and AXL, and
co-expression of these receptors is associated with
cetuximab resistance.
We know that inhibition of EGFR and HER
family members more generally fosters a partial EMT or
indeed a full out epithelial to mesenchymal transition, and this is
associated with treatment resistance.
And
Amanda Psiri and David Rim have shown that EGFR can be
translocated to the nucleus where it sort of hides from
cetuximab.
So,
one of the things that's been sort of interesting is that
there've been a lot of clinical trials with the pan-HER
inhibitor afatinib, which have really failed to show much of an
advance over cetuximab alone. Here, Jungwoo Lee in the
lab developed some afatinib- and erlotinib-resistant
cell line models, and working with Flavio Silva at Fox
Chase, we looked at induction of EMT in these
models. So first of all, it appeared as if
the pan-HER inhibition more strongly drove
EMT than
erlotinib alone, and I'll come back to that for some therapeutic implications at
the end of the talk.Well, I mentioned that cetuximab
cannot access EGFR when it's located in the nucleus.
Nuclear EGFR is known to have some non-canonical effects in stabilizing
PCNA. So we undertook a trial where we looked at adding
a TKI, which would be able to access the receptor
intracellularly to the combination of chemotherapy and
cetuximab, and this was reported by Aarti Batia last
year. So when we gave chemotherapy and cetuximab together in cycle one,
that led to an objective response rate of 33%, spot on for what
the randomized phase three trial had shown.
When we added erlotinib in cycle two, this increased the response rate
to 62.5%.
And I'd like to talk you through some of the post-treatment biopsies that we got on
this study. So first of all, this
case that I picked out of a responder,
I want to start out by highlighting had no P10 expression, which ordinarily is
associated with resistance to cetuximab.
And then down here we have the EGFR expression.
After one cycle of treatment with cetuximab, there's downregulation
of the amount of EGFR expressed, but there's persistence of intracellular
and nuclear EGFR in a subset of the cells.
And then when we added erlotinib, that's completely abrogated.
So I think highlighting and as I talk about some of the bispecifics in a second,
the idea that you can enhance degradation of EGFR might be very
important to addressing nuclear EGFR function.
So after several decades of the only EGFR inhibitor that's been
available to us in head-neck cancer has been cetuximab,
now there are some clinical trials moving forward with bispecifics
that critically address EMT and
early induction of resistance. And so I'd like to talk through some of those.
I'm sorry that because of time, I can't also address antibody combinations
and antibody drug conjugates.
So the first I'd like to talk about is ficaserafusp.
This is a bispecific that targets EGFR and TGF-beta.
And although as a monotherapy, it had a very low response rate,
one out of 42 patients, we've seen very exciting data in
combination with pembrolizumab.
So here you see ficaserafusp plus
pembrolizumab in HPV negative PD-L1 expressing cancers with
a response rate of 54%. And even more remarkably, I
think a median overall survival for this HPV negative population
over 20 months.
Dan Zandberg presented at the multidisciplinary meeting in February
some correlative data from the single-arm experience where
profound neutralization of TGF-beta was observed, and also
induction of tumoral CD8 cells. And so this is now
moving forward as a phase three trial called
FORTIFY-HN01, where patients are randomized between
ficaserafusp plus pembrolizumab or placebo plus
pembrolizumab with
primary endpoints of objective response and overall survival.
Next, pitaseptumab. This is another EGFR bispecific.
This co-targets LGR5, not actually a very
abundantly expressed
protein in head-neck cancer.
Actually, almost not expressed on the mature cells,
seems to be predominantly expressed on stem cells, but it is
upregulated in EMT and following EGFR
inhibition. And the
maker of this product has pre-clinical data demonstrating that it does
foster pretty dramatic EGFR degradation.
So this has also been explored both as monotherapy and in
combination with pembrolizumab.
I'm showing you the combination data here, where for HPV negative
patients, you have an objective response rate of
66%.
And this holds in the PD-L1, one to
19 or greater than 20 population. So there are two phase
three trials now ongoing with this agent.
The first one in previously untreated patients in combination
with pembrolizumab up against pembro alone, and the other in
previously treated patients comparing pembro to investigator's
choice chemotherapy.
And then the last one I wanted to speak about briefly is amivantamab.
This is an agent that's already in use for lung cancer.
It co-targets EGFR with MET, and it has both
single-agent activity at 45% in treatment-refractory patients
and a combination objective response rate of 56% in
combination with pembrolizumab in first line.
And as you can see from the
spider plot there, responses can be quite deep and
durable for these patients. And this is now moving forward in a randomized trial
for a somewhat different group of patients.
So these are the patients where investigators are likely to prefer a combination of
pembrolizumab with chemotherapy.
So you're expecting more symptomatic, higher
tumor burden patients to enter this trial.
And they'll either get the chemo pembro regimen from
KEYNOTE-048 or pembrolizumab, carboplatin, and
amivantamab with a primary endpoint of overall survival.
So let me turn now to our failure to
capitalize on the genomic landscape of head-neck cancer.
So in HPV negative head-neck cancer, the mutational landscape is dominated by
loss of tumor suppressor function, and the most common event here is
p53 mutation, and the second most common event, probably
CDKN2A. So 85% of these cases have
mutation in p53.
If you look at what these mutations are, starting over here
you see quite a large number of them are truncation mutations, which means
that pharmacologic agents which aim to stabilize and
foster a more normal conformation of a mutated protein are
unlikely to succeed. And if you look at the
location of the missense mutations, many of them are in the DNA
binding domain. And so the overwhelming majority of these mutations lead to loss of
function.So my lab is interested in what are
targetable regulators of G2M that might lead to synthetic
lethal therapies when P53 is mutated, and you don't have good
regulation of G1 to S. And you'll see that quite
a large number of these targets have agents that are
currently in development. We focused on Aurora A.
So this is a mitotic entry kinase. Its
longest, best understood role is in fostering the spindle assembly
complex. It's reciprocally regulated by P53, so when you have loss
of P53, you get more Aurora A. And we had previously
shown that increased Aurora A correlated with poor prognosis and platinum
resistance in patients who were treated with curative resection and
postoperative chemoradiation.
One of the things, and so I'm not sure how well this projects for you,
but this is a
immunofluorescence where the red stain is directed
at Aurora. And one of the things that was quite surprising to us was that
the prognostic signal was strongest when we were focused on
nuclear Aurora. And so I don't know if you can appreciate that the blue
DAPI-stained nuclei are also co-staining for Aurora
in this tumor up here. And so
a number of people in the Aurora field told me that there must be something wrong
with our assay because Aurora didn't go to the nucleus.
And it took a long time for us to understand that better.
But as work went forward demonstrating that the Aurora
TPX2 complex has a role in protecting
replication forks, we went back to look at this in more
detail, and using DNA fiber assay, we were able to show that
when you added
a Aurora inhibitor, in this case VIC-1911,
you could
inhibit replication fork progression.
So you start with the red-labeled chlorodeoxyuridine, then you
chase it with a green-labeled iodo, and you can see that there's very little
incorporation of green after Aurora inhibition.
So we took this fur-- I should say, much of this is
work of Jong Woo Lee in the lab. So we took this further, looking
at other marks of replication stress, and we were able
to see that
R-loop formation was dramatically increased either by
Aurora inhibition alone or in combination with WEE1 inhibition.
I'll get there in a second. That we saw DNA damage
response as reflected in the hallmark UV signature, and
that we were able to show using IP that we were inducing
phosphorylation activation of WEE1, and that led to
phosphorylation of CDK2, as well as an increase
in cyclin E in cells that were being released from thymidine block.
So we asked ourselves, was this creating a dependency
on WEE1?
And
here we've
treated cells either with alisertib or with the davisertib.
So alisertib is a Aurora inhibitor.
Davisertib's a WEE1 inhibitor. When we gave the Aurora
inhibitor, you can see that there was dramatic phosphorylation of CDK1,
which is a result of the activation of WEE1.
And this leads to cell cycle arrest, and it may be one of the reasons that Aurora
inhibitors as monotherapy have not been more successful, and we
were able to show this across a couple of different P53 mutated
cell lines.
We showed that when we combined an Aurora inhibitor with a
WEE1 inhibitor, each one of them inducing a modicum of
replication stress, we really were able to abrogate replication
fork progression entirely with combination therapy.
Using PLA for PCNA and RNA Pol II
to look for transcription replication conflict, you can see some of that is induced
by the Aurora inhibitor, but it's massively increased with combination
therapy. And then looking at phospho RPA2, again as a marker of
replication fork stalling, this is dramatically increased in the combination
therapy. And I think this
mitotic catastrophe phenotype here is a little preview of what I'm
going to be showing you about the anticancer effects of this
combination. So we screened a panel of head and neck
non-small cell, a couple of other tumor types with P53 mutation,
including pancreatic. And we were able to show that across all of the
models we studied, with the exception of this one head and neck cancer cell line,
SCC61, that has a CDC25 mutation and is
really resistant to WEE1 inhibition.
But across all the other cell lines, we saw a synergy, whether you looked at
the lowest synergy score and integrated
scoring system.
When we did live cell imaging, I think you can appreciate here in the
Aurora inhibitor-treated cells, they really become quite
quiescent after Aurora inhibition.
But with combination therapy, we started to see mitotic catastrophe
within the first day, and most cells were dead by 40
hours. The
morphology, I think, is pretty interesting here as well.
So this is the Aurora inhibition, and you can see with the inability
to align the spindle appropriately, you get these
four spindle poles.
And then when you combine the two treatments, you get a mitotic catastrophe
phenotype. This is active in vivo.
So here you have a Fadu xenograft showing
monotherapy up here in the more autumnal colors and combination
therapy in the more spring-like colors with a dose-response relationship and
good tumor control at a tolerable dose of 120 and 120.
And here in a PDX established from one of our patients at Yale,
very dramatic tumor control with combination.
Well, I started out by telling you that I was interested in this because I thought
it was going to be related to P53. So we went back and looked at this
across a panel of isogenic P53Wild
type null, gain-of-function, loss-of-function mutation cells, which
were a kind gift from Jeff Myers. And you can see that across the
p53 abnormal cell lines in comparison to wild type,
induction of cleaved
PARP and induction of gamma-H2AX are tightly linked
to p53 abnormality. And in fact, our
synergy is completely correlated to p53 genotype.
So the model that we
think that we've worked out here is, loss of p53
increases dependence on Aurora, increases expression of Aurora.
When you inhibit Aurora,
you lead to a
dysregulation or interference with spindle assembly, but you also
lead to cell cycle arrest that's mediated by WEE1, and that
eventuates because of the replication stress that Aurora
is failing to protect against
in the nucleus. When you then target WEE1, you have no
restraint of mitotic entry in the cell with its inadequate,
incompetent spindle assembly
products, is unable to complete a normal mitosis, and you get
micronuclei formation and mitotic catastrophe.
And
we are taking this forward in the combo match mechanism.
We
have, I think, gotten the go-ahead to use p53 rather
than cyclin E as our biomarker for enrolling patients,
partly because the Aurora inhibition seems to induce the same level of
cyclin E that's being used in other trials of WEE1 inhibitors for patient
selection. And then I promised you I would circle back to
EGFR adaptive resistance. So these are the same
afatinib-resistant models that
we used for the EMT experiments. And what you can see here is that
the combination of an Aurora and a WEE1 inhibitor is highly
synergistic, not only in the parental cells but also in the
afatinib-resistant cells. And we actually think Aurora dependence is
increased in the setting of afatinib resistance because
this is an important
component of the EMT response.
So hopefully, I've shown you that novel EGFR bispecifics that focus
on targets related to known resistance mechanisms are moving forward.
That higher response rates in combination with PD1 inhibition have led to
Phase III trials. That I anticipate that we're going to be dealing
with adaptive resistance after those kind of combinations as our next
therapeutic challenge in the field, and
that investigational approaches to that
phenomenon are going to be of interest.
And that a p53 mutation remains the holy grail in
HPV-negative head-neck cancer, and that we think that
targeting
the choreography of the G2M transition with combined
Aurora and WEE1
therapy may be one way to approach those cancers.
And all of this obviously didn't happen without the help of a lot of people.
I'd like to particularly call out Jung Woo Lee and Jackie Shi in my lab, and
Flavia Silva in Erica's lab at Fox Chase.
Thank my funding agencies. And I think we have a couple of minutes for
questions, so thank you very much.
And if you have a question, please come to the microphone because we are streaming,
and otherwise, the people online won't be able to hear you.
Barbara, can I ask a question?
Yeah, please.
So,
you showed the different classes of
TP53 mutation
across TP53 mutated head and neck cancer.
I'm curious on your thoughts,
are there particular mutational phenotypes that may
lend themselves in particular to the
Aurora-WEE1 combinatorial strategies that you
talked about?
So I think as long as there's loss of p53 function,
we are not aware of any. However, I think the co-mutation story is going to be
important to pay attention to. And we screened a lot of cell
lines before we found one where Aurora
didn't induce replication stress and where the combination wasn't
synergistic. And when we looked at the mutations in that, it
was obvious that it was bypassing
Aurora and WEE1, right? So, I think
there's going to be subway maps to make of where those
resistance mechanisms are located.
I kind of dismissed the p53 stabilizers.
I think that there are some mutations that are in the DNA binding domain that would
be amenable to that approach, and Jeff Myers' group has obviously worked on that.
And then some of these new approaches where you can try to
foster DNA replication to move past a truncation mutation,
haven't been tried here, but I think could be of real interest as
well.
So hi.
Yeah, hi.
Hi. Pier Paolo Claudio. I have a question regarding the
replication of
NPL2. So CDK9 actually phosphorylates PL2.
Have you investigated the role of CDK9 in this?
And also, have you investigated
retinoblastoma? Because it's not just p53, but any, because it's
a G1S block. So,
also that.
Yes.
Thank you.
Those are great questions. CDK9 has not really come out of our
RNA-seq or proteomics as a big hit, but we haven't
specifically interrogated it. In terms of RB,
I will say that we have more trouble
seeing activity of this combination in HPV-associated
cancers where RB is
degraded.Although
aurora does play a really interesting role in adaptive resistance to
pan-HER inhibition in that setting.
So,
I do think that Rb is also a really important
question.
Okay.
Thank you all very much. So now I'm really pleased to introduce
Dale Yarbrough, who's going to talk about
HPV-associated cancer.
Use this to advance and use that as your mouse.
Roger.
All right. Well,
thanks, Barbara. I'd like to thank you for inviting me, and
the organizers. We're going to talk about something that's a little bit
different, talk about HPV-associated cancers.
I'm Dale Yarbrough from UNC, and I'd like to tell you
today about some studies that have progressed in our
lab over the last several years that identify a
biomarker and a new treatment for
HPV-associated cancer,
and moving towards precision medicine.
So just a little bit of history with HPV.
It hasn't been all that long ago, in the mid-'70s, Harald zur
Hausen
associated causality of HPV with uterine
cervical cancer, and 30 years later got the Nobel Prize for it.
But you can see some of the key players here that uncovered
carcinogenesis. Karl Munger and Denise Galloway really did
seminal work on E6 and E7 functions to inhibit
p53 and Rb. You can see the genomics and
epidemiology
contributions here. But I'd like to really point out the vaccine that was
enabled by the development of virus-like particles from Doug Lowy
and John Schiller.
Now, head and neck cancer association with HPV came much
later than this, although
Frans van Abb ringen
described
HPV in head and neck cancers very early on.
But Margillison's group really,
along with others, popularized the causality in head and neck
cancer. And Lewis and Westra
worked to establish p16 as a surrogate marker
of the disease. Sturgis and Chadhavedi described
epidemiology, along with the Hopkins group, where this
disease has continued to increase over the years.
Many leaders in the fields have addressed deescalation with
surgery,
induction therapy, cetuximab, and
commonly using smoking and tumor stage,
including Bob Ferris and Biswam Chara, Sue
Yam, and
our own Barbara Burtness.
One thing that wasn't really addressed by this was
carcinogenesis, and that's totally understandable.
No one would have any idea that just affecting a different area of the
body would change how HPV creates
cancer
or infects the cells. But our group really
had a clue to this when we started working on subtypes,
and one of the first clues for the
subtype was discovery of mutations of two NF-kappa B
regulators that came out of the TCGA, TRAF3 and CYLD.
And
these mutations were rare in HPV negative tumors,
and their absence in uterine cervical cancer was really an early
signal that there may be a different HPV carcinogenesis pathway in
action.
We also noted that tumors harboring these mutations
in TRAF or CYLD had improved survival.
We went on to confirm these results using unsupervised gene
expression analysis,
which found that
one expression cluster, the sky blue in the pie chart,
naturally segregated tumors into subtypes based on high or
low expression, as shown in the histogram below.
Remarkably, gene set enrichment analysis revealed that NF-kappa B
activation was the defining characteristic of the expressed
genes in this cluster.
And all deactivating mutations of TRAF3 or CYLD were
found in the low-risk subtype identified by these
clusters, confirming that this analysis
basically identified the same subtypes that were identified by
mutation analysis.
Using this expression set, a high-risk and low-risk
subtype of HPV-associated carcinoma
were defined with tumors in the high-risk subtype in the gold
and red, and in the low risk,
having worse survival than the low-risk subtypes, which are in the blue and
black. As you can see, smoking did not decrease
survival in the low-risk subtype, as shown by the overlap of the blue and black
lines in the low-risk subtype.
So this is a schematic of HPV
carcinogenesis that was described in uterine cervical cancer.
And one key part of that is viral integration
that occurs and leads to a downregulation of E2
or loss of E2 expression, which upregulates E6 and E7, causing
critical dysfunction in p53 and Rb.
That, along with other genetic and epigenetic
alterations, leads to cancer. And this was the
canonical HPV carcinogenesis mechanism.
What our work has led to is
this new
schematic on this slide that shows a representation of
the non-canonical HPV carcinogenesis that was discovered in
head and neck squamous cell carcinoma.There are many differences
compared to uterine cervical cancer carcinogenesis,
including that almost all of these are caused by HPV type 16,
with HPV 18 being very rare.
Modest E6 and modest E7 expression,
perhaps best demonstrated by RB1 mutations that occur
in head and neck cancers but not in uterine cervical cancers because E7 is
not adequate to totally inactivate RB.
Maintenance of episomal HPV without signs of
integration in some tumors, and E2 being expressed at high
levels.
And of course, more genetic and epigenetic alterations
are required, but they're different between uterine cervical cancer and
the two subtypes. And this is all best described
by NF-kappa B associated transcriptional state that
can distinguish these two subtypes.
Most importantly, these tumors that are in the non-canonical
HPV carcinogenesis are sensitive to radiation, and I'll get to that, and they
have improved survival, and we've shown some of that already.
So this slide defines the differences between the subtypes of HPV
positive head and neck cancer. Some notable differences that we have
discussed already are mutations in NF-kappa B
regulators,
HPV gene expression, and HPV integration.
It's also interesting that some markers correlating with survival in HPV
positive cancer differ between subtypes,
with higher
ER alpha PIK3CA mutations
and estrogen receptor
alpha expression.
Low-risk tumors are more sensitive to radiation, and we'll
get to that a little bit later. And most importantly, the low-risk
tumors have better survival.
So what I've shown so far is that HPV positive oropharyngeal
squamous cell carcinomas can be divided into biological distinct
subtypes with very different clinical outcomes.
What's important here is that these differences are not just descriptive or a
black box, or defined by
analysis that looked for differences in survival.
They are mechanistically grounded
using isogenic cell lines,
focusing on differences between low-risk and high-risk HPV
positive subtypes, which consistently correlate with improved
survival.
One of the key features that we uncovered is that the low-risk subtype is
intrinsically sensitive to radiation.
On the right, we're looking at clonogenic survival assays using a
high-risk UM-SCC-47 HPV positive
cell line. In the parental cells, we see the expected
degree
of radiation resistance, but when we disrupt TRAF3,
pushing the cells to the NF-kappa B active state, we see a
marked increase in radiation sensitivity across doses.
The difference in radiation sensitivity isn't subtle.
The cell survival curves separate early and continue to diverge,
and the difference is highly significant.
What this tells us
is that the biology defining the low risk subtype
directly modulates survival after radiation, and in other
words, improved survival in patients isn't just because these
tumors are smaller or detected earlier or because of smoking
habits.
It's because their underlying signaling state makes them more
vulnerable to radiation-induced cell death.
This provides a mechanistic explanation for why the low-risk subtype
does so well clinically and why radiation de-escalation is
biologically plausible in this group.
More subtly, these findings also suggest that resistant tumors can be
sensitized to radiation.
This slide puts the emerging biomarkers for HPV positive cancer
into context by comparing hazard ratios for survival.
What stands out is that the biologically defined HPV subtypes show the
largest effect sizes, substantially greater than
genomic or immune biomarkers. In particular, the high risk
versus low risk HPV subtypes consistently showed a hazard ratio of
greater than 3.5.
I've been at a lot of talks today talking about hazard ratios of 1.5,
1.2 at plenary sessions.
This is a 3.5. All right.
Across many cohorts, an exclusion of the training
cohorts does not change the hazard ratio, as shown by the
second bar from the top.
By contrast, immune phenotypes and single gene
alterations such as NSD1, ER alpha, and
PIK3CA mutations have lower hazard
ratios in fewer cohorts, in patients
that they have compared. Taken together, these data suggest that biological
HPV subtypes capture a dominant tumor behavior
and may represent a stronger framework for risk stratification and
therapeutic tailoring than other biomarkers.
So success in sensitization of the high-risk
subtype through TRAF3 or CYLD knockout led us to determine if
NF-kappa B activation with drugs would
also sensitize high-risk subtype.
At the time, we were excited about SMAC mimetics because of an
ongoing trial of zaveditinib plus chemoradiation
therapy in head neck cancerWe tested several SMAC
mimetics, and shown here is birinapant,
which activated NF-kappa B, as shown by the reporter assay at the bottom,
and in the high-risk UMSCC47 cells.
Unfortunately, results of the TrialNEX trial, with overall
survival shown on the right, showed that xavanapant plus chemoradiation
therapy resulted in worse survival than chemoradiation therapy
alone for locally advanced head and neck squamous cell carcinoma,
and this led us to abandon this strategy.
However, the silver lining is that this data, plus our
TRAF and CYLD knockout data,
showed that NF-kappa B activation was sufficient to sensitize
high-risk subtype of head and neck cancer and
led us to test other NF-kappa B activators.
So I'm not going to show all of the data because of time,
but I will show some mouse data.
We created an immunocompetent mouse model of the high-risk
HPV head and neck squamous cell carcinoma subtype and tested if the
toll-like receptor 5 agonist would sensitize
isografts to radiation.
The spider plot and Kaplan-Meier curves show that the combination of radiation
plus the toll-like receptor 5 agonist entolimod sensitized
high-risk subtype tumors,
with one mouse being cured with the combination treatment.
An advantage of entolimod is that it was developed as a radiation
protectant for normal tissues. So while it
sensitizes the cancer cells to
radiation, it makes normal tissues more resistant.
So I hope that I've provided convincing evidence that
HPV-positive oropharyngeal squamous cell carcinoma
is not a single disease and it's not simply uterine
cervical cancer moved north, but that it consists of two
biologically distinct subtypes defined by different mechanisms
of HPV carcinogenesis. These subtypes have markedly
different outcomes,
with the low-risk subtype showing substantially better survival and
greater radiation sensitivity. Importantly,
understanding these differences
opens the door to biologically informed treatment strategies.
And this slide really gets at the conclusions about why
these two subtypes matter clinically.
HPV-positive oropharyngeal squamous cell carcinoma has
historically been treated as one disease.
But doing that is exactly why large de-escalation trials
have not shown efficacy. The low-risk
subtype is intrinsically sensitive to radiation.
These patients do extremely well,
and they are
the appropriate population for radiation de-escalation,
to maximize cure while meaningfully reducing long-term toxicity.
In contrast, the high-risk subtype behaves very differently.
These tumors are not appropriate for de-escalation,
that may compromise tumor control.
Instead, these tumors require
standard or intensified local therapy.
Importantly, this isn't a group that we should treat more
aggressively or just treat more aggressively, it's also a group where
biology gives us leverage.
One new therapy that I've not discussed here is demethylation that's
based on excess genome methylation seen in HPV-positive
tumors, particularly the high-risk subtype.
We have a trial open at Yale with Barbara as the PI, and Mike
Tarazi, who's in the audience,
has a poster tomorrow describing the effects of this therapy to
increase immune infiltration and turn colder tumors hot.
And it's tomorrow between
9:00 and 12:00 in poster session 43. I hope everybody will stop by.
And so here we have shown that activating NF-kappa B
signaling can sensitize high-risk tumors to
radiation and that entolimod allows us to
simultaneously protect normal tissues.
The improved therapeutic ratio should improve tumor control by
decreasing radiation side effects.
Understanding the biology of these subtypes reframes
how we think about tumor de-escalation, not as a global
strategy, but as one that must be biologically selective.
And we now have a biomarker to help
guide therapy.
What's exciting to me is that these findings have the potential to
move us from imprecise patient selection to
predictive decision-making for care of these patients.
And I'd just like to thank all the people who did the work.
This is a big group, but the UNC head and neck lab,
co-led with Natalia Isaeva and Travis Schrock,
have contributed immensely to this.
I'm happy to answer any questions.
So if you have any questions,
please come to the microphone because otherwise the people online can't hear you.
Yeah, go ahead.
Hi, Dr. Yarbrough, thanks for the great talk, and thanks for sharing those exciting
findings. It's interesting to see that those low-risk subtype only exist in
OPSCC, but does not exist in cervical cancer.
I'm curious if you have any thoughts on why.
Do you think it's more because of the environment, or the tissue differences, or
anything else?
Excellent question. I wish I knew.
We have thought about that.And,
as we talked about a little bit yesterday, there may be a subset in anal
cancer that actually have these mutations, and this subtype may
occur, but it's not as common. I do not know.
I suspect that it is related to the specialized
cell at the base of the tonsillar crypts that sort of
acts as a pseudo-antigen presenting cell with the lymphoepithelioma,
as opposed to the uterine cervix,
which has a more standard stratified squamous epithelium.
But I'll say I don't know.
Thank you.
Thank you for the great talk. Gusmann from Cologne, Germany.
How is your concordance with episomal or integrated
HPV
DNA in these both groups? Is there any correlation to
integration status?
Yeah, there is.
So
when we look at integration, there's some of the
low-risk tumors that have no integration at all, but there are some that
have some integration. But what we've found is when we look carefully,
the integration in those low-risk tumors that
have NF-kappa V active still maintain episomes,
and the integration affects surrounding
somatic genes more than it affects HPV gene
expression. So E2 is not lost in those integration
events, but the surrounding gene's expression
is changed. Whereas if we look at uterine cervical cancer,
almost all the integration events disrupt E2 and cause elevated
E6 and E7.
Go ahead.
Thanks for the great talk. I appreciate it.
We do both uterine cervix and head and neck based on HPV, so it's wonderful
to see the stratification between the two types.
I'm wondering, even though HPV 16/18 causes the majority, have you looked at
other rare types like 31, 33, 52?
As far as
having two subtypes, we have not.
We do see
the rare subtypes. I will say their survival tends to be
worse than the good
subtype of HPV positive head and neck cancer.
So both subtypes could exist, we just
haven't looked.
Yes, it's a rare event, and we just don't have a large number of tumors to look
at.
We have the same problem, so I totally understand.
Okay.
If I can ask a follow-up question,
most of the genetic studies we do is through Oxford Nanopore long-read
sequencing. Have you considered using that approach versus standard whole exome or
things like that for most of the driver mutation investigations?
We have done some long sequencing.
It was mostly to look for integration sites and things like that.
But we haven't really,
I would say,
explored that deeply in head and neck cancer.
Thanks so much. Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Two questions, if I may.
The first is, is there any relationship between subtype
and the baseline
HPV circulating tumoral DNA that people are
measuring?
Yeah. That's a very interesting question, and
we recently got some data
from a biomarker study we're doing that's preliminary.
But about half the patients in that, and it's only on 70 patients,
but about half the patients are in each subtype.
And there was a marked difference in circulating tumor
DNA between the two subtypes.
Being higher in the worse, in other words, or-
Being higher in the better prognosis group.
Oh.
Yeah.
Interesting. Okay.
And then my second question,
and I know you've thought about this because we've talked about it in the past, but
is there a way to begin to use this as a prospective
biomarker in clinical trials of treatment deintensification?
Yeah. Thanks for asking that question. I would love to see that.
We're putting together a protocol now
for a grant application
to use that exactly as a stratifier for
deescalation therapy. And I think that it's reasonable to think about
in the future combining it with other
markers of response, like circulating tumor DNA.
But
we do think that this group, because of the
intrinsic radiation sensitivity, is going to
be the group that's going to have the most marked responses.
Wonderful. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay. And so now I'd like to introduce Dr.
Ari Rosenberg from the University of
Chicago to talk to us about using minimal residual disease for
treatment optimization in head and neck cancer.
Great. Thank you, and thank you, Barbara, and the organizers for
the invitation to speak at this excellent meeting.
So over the next several minutes, I'll shift gears a little bit, but hopefully
touch on some of the themes that you've heard about already, talking about
minimal residual disease and treatment optimization in head and neck cancer.
So here are my disclosures.
So we heard about the two distinct biological subtypes that we
see in our clinic. We have the HPV-associated disease, which Dale
spoke about so eloquently, in which the prognosis is more favorable
and where much of the therapeutic efforts have been on trying
to deescalate treatment or some of these patients to try to
reduce some of the treatment-related toxicity.And then we also have the
HPV negative or HPV unrelated head and neck cancers for
which, even in the immunotherapy era, prognosis is
quite modest, and there's extensive room for
improving outcomes for this disease subtype.
And so our treatment goal is, in both cases, improving survival while also
optimizing long-term function and quality of life.
And in head and neck, we've had a bit of a paucity of reliable
biomarkers to really guide most of our systemic therapeutic decision making.
So as you heard about, actually, there's been lots of discussion across the whole
meeting, circulating tumor DNA represents a very appealing non-invasive
blood based biomarker. Of course, this represents the cell-free
DNA fraction that originates from tumor cells with tumor specific
alterations, and can be detected and measured as a variant or
mutant allele frequency,
and can provide real time window into tumor burden,
disease evolution, and clonal dynamics.
In head and neck, there's multiple different therapeutic time points in
which this has potential applications, from screening and
detection,
to baseline profiling and prognostication.
So at the time of diagnosis, when the therapeutic decision
making is happening.
On treatment disease kinetics or grading of treatment response
across all phases of therapy, from neoadjuvant
to definitive to even adjuvant. In a surveillance post-treatment
setting to look for or measure minimal residual disease, and in the recurrent
metastatic setting to monitor and grade therapeutic
response.
Across all of these treatment settings, the real question
that at least I'm interested in is:
how can we adapt the treatment to ultimately improve
outcomes for our patients?
The strategies and technical characteristics can be categorized in a
number of different ways. One of the ways that they can be categorized is as
tumor-informed versus tumor-agnostic approaches.
Of course, tumor-informed requires tumor tissue, oftentimes
generating a patient specific assay does take more
time, but can have lower limits of detection.
You can see some examples within the head and neck cancer space written below.
Tumor agnostic, on the other hand, is oftentimes ready for use and cheaper.
Does not require tumor tissue, which for a disease like head and neck cancer,
often treated non-surgically, can be a potential clinical
advantage. It is the same assay for the whole patient population,
can potentially detect emerging clones.
Oftentimes, at least in terms of the mutational NGS assays, can have
lower sensitivity, however. Some examples of these include the viral specific
assays, mutational panels, and methylation
classifiers. Again, limit of detection, oftentimes
deeper in the tumor-informed as compared with some of the broad NGS assays,
although methylation and viral directed may be able to improve
detection. And again, importantly, the technical
characteristics should actually fit the clinical application.
In addition to the clinical parameters of the assay, the
schedule of the surveillance, whether it's a one-time landmark time point or
whether it's multiple time points, may also affect important clinical
parameters such as lead time, as you can see here.
So we'll start by HPV-associated head and neck cancer, and this
really lends itself to using MRD as a plasma-based
assay as a key tool. Number one, because there's a
tumor agnostic viral target with HPV that you heard about
from Del's talk, allowing highly sensitive and specific
detection with a couple of different
technologies, both ddPCR and NGS based assays, both of
which commercially available. Recurrence pattern for HPV positive head and
neck cancer, these tend to recur later, oftentimes at distant sites,
often at non-pulmonary sites, again, lending itself to a plasma-based
surveillance strategy. And oftentimes these are treated non-surgically, such
that a tissue agnostic approach may be particularly appealing.
There's a number of different assays in which MRD in a surveillance setting
has demonstrated high sensitivity and specificity.
These are one of these assays with a ddPCR based assay in a
prospective study, as you can see here.
Again, baseline detection, 86%. So
we are still missing some of these at baseline, and again, very high
positive predictive value. But of the 15 recurrences, while most were
captured, there were four false negatives as well.
So again, highlighting the opportunity to improve the
technical
ability of these assays to detect in terms of
sensitivity.
There's been a number of different strategies of looking at the dynamics during
treatment in order to further classify
these
HPV subtypes in terms of prognosis.
And this is just one of those studies from Dr.
Sherrill when he was at UNC still, who identified a favorable
kinetic cohort with over 200 copies at baseline,
as well as over 95% clearance by mid-treatment, again, with
the most favorable cohort. Whereas the unfavorable kinetic
profile, both across low and higher clinical risk patients,
had worse progression-free survival.
So again, potentially be able to add to the clinical
value of highlighting a cohort of patients that may be good
candidates for de-escalation or even therapeutic
intensification. What about in the neoadjuvant phase?
So, this is retrospective subset analysis data
from our OPTIMA 2 trial, which we ran in our center, which was a neoadjuvant
chemoimmunotherapy trial with response adaptive de-escalation.
And again, the patients that cleared their ctDNA during the neoadjuvant
phase had more favorable progression free survival as compared with those
patients that failed to clear their ctDNA during the neoadjuvant
phase.How early
can these changes be helpful in terms of informing some of the
clinical parameters that we care about? It turns out, very early.
This is data from a prospective biomarker study
that we ran of neoadjuvant chemo and response adaptive de-escalation, where we
checked ctDNA using an HPV-seq
NGS-based assay after every cycle of neoadjuvant
chemo, during de-escalated treatment, and then in a post-treatment setting.
And again, rapid clearance after just one cycle of neoadjuvant
chemotherapy predicted response, and as with many of the other assays,
detection three months or later following definitive treatment
associated with worse progression-free survival.
It turns out, with some of these very sensitive assays, the lead time can be
quite prolonged in terms of MRD. So this is one of the patients that we
treated on this prospective biomarker study who completed response adaptive
de-escalation, and already three months post-treatment had
detectable and quantifiable MRD.
And it wasn't until over two years later that this patient was
ultimately diagnosed with recurrent metastatic
HPV-positive head and neck squamous cell carcinoma.
So again, highlighting the potential opportunity to
intervene earlier on MRD in the post-treatment
definitive setting.
So what about interventional trials that try to leverage these
findings in order to improve outcomes for patients?
This is data from the Dana-Farber group that we saw presented last year at
ASCO,
where they looked and included both clinical and biomarker
risk in their de-escalation strategy.
So low clinical risk patients all received de-escalated chemoradiation
to 60 gray, whereas higher clinical risk patients were
either stratified as a favorable kinetic profile and received de-escalated
chemoradiation, or unfavorable kinetic profile and received
standard chemoradiation. And these investigators identified
that the two-year PFS was 90% overall, and this
seemed similar across the initial
low-risk clinical patients, as well as the
higher HPV-positive clinical risk patients, but with a
favorable ctDNA profile. Again,
suggesting that this may add to the baseline clinical risk
value and may at least give a hint that this could be
potentially validated in larger prospective studies.
What about in the adjuvant settings?
This is data we saw from Memorial Sloan Kettering Group, presented and published
by Linda Chen when she was there before she came to join us at University of
Chicago. This was a study that looked at the transoral robotic
surgery patients for HPV-positive head and neck cancer with intermediate
pathologic features, where instead of giving adjuvant
radiation standardly, they tested an
approach of HPV DNA surveillance with a plan of
then administering adjuvant radiation when the HPV DNA turns positive.
Unfortunately, they identified actually that a quarter of patients
ultimately developed gross recurrence of disease.
And in this quarter of patients, actually, the HPV
DNA turned positive either synchronously with the gross recurrence,
or there was gross recurrent disease before the HPV
DNA was detectable in plasma. Again, highlighting the
need to further optimize these biomarkers for
clinical deployment.
What about de-escalating treatment based on a MRD
biomarker rather than eliminating altogether?
This is being explored out of the Emory group.
This is a trial that Dr. Bates updated us at the
multidisciplinary meeting earlier this year with favorable risk HPV-positive
head and neck cancer patients who underwent transoral robotic surgery, had, again,
intermediate pathologic risk, and received biomarker
stratified adjuvant treatment. So the patients who were positive
post-surgery received 50 to 60 gray of adjuvant radiation, whereas
the negative patients received de-escalated adjuvant radiation of 36
gray. And again, in the second interim analysis,
90% had post-op ctDNA negative, so received de-escalated
radiation. And then again, at least at this early look,
12-month local regional control, 96%.
Again, we look forward to seeing more mature results from this study.
What about in larger adjuvant de-escalation studies?
This is a secondary analysis from the Mayo group's
DART de-escalation study, where they explored adjuvant of
36 gray with concurrent chemotherapy and some
hyperfractionation. And again, this finding that MRD
is helpful both in the post-op setting as well as at the three-month
post-treatment setting across all pathologic risk
categories in terms of predicting
progression-free survival. And this is being incorporated as
part of the de-escalation decision-making in their ongoing DART-2 study.
What about patients that fail to clear MRD with complete
treatment or become MRD positive in the surveillance setting?
We've shown that these patients are almost guaranteed to
develop recurrence at some point.
This is an ongoing randomized Phase 2 trial of cemiplimab, PD-1
inhibitor, with or without fianlimab, a LAG-3 inhibitor, in
MRD positive patients after definitive treatment.
Again, these are patients who, in the context of commercial MRD
surveillance, is either positive post-treatment or becomes positive
post-treatment and are being randomized to PD-1 alone or in combination
with LAG-3 inhibitor with a primary recurrence-free survival
endpoint, and then we developed this trial along with Sid Sheth from
UNC as well.Just to highlight other
directions besides trying to improve the technical aspects of
these assays, but also trying to improve the way that we deploy them in clinic.
This is an example of that with
work that was led by Dr. Pearson from my group, along with Dr.
Mohammadi, where they developed a machine learning
ctDNA deployment optimization model that
developed a personalized surveillance schedule based on
smoking status and stage. So again, taking into account
cost as well as treatment delays, and again, just to highlight that
we can deploy some of these newer tools, of which there's lots of discussion at
this meeting, such as machine learning strategies, to try to
personalize and use other parameters to also optimize the
deployment within the clinic.
So now I'll pivot to virus-unrelated head and neck cancer.
This is a disease, as we've spoken about, with worse prognosis, quite
heterogeneous, and also heterogeneous in terms of the ctDNA technologies that are
being deployed in this particular setting.
It is being evaluated across multiple disease settings, though.
And the question becomes: where is there potential for MRD to add
clinical value across the different therapeutic settings with this disease?
This is a summary of the various heterogeneous ctDNA
technologies that are being explored in virus-unrelated head and neck cancer, from
targeted NGS-based assays to tumor-informed
assays, as you can see here, as well as tissue-agnostic
genome-wide methylome enrichment assays, and again, across different
disease settings, and so quite a heterogeneous field, at least right
now. But what do we know about ctDNA and
virus-unrelated head and neck cancer?
Well, pretty consistently, we see that baseline detection is in
approximately three-quarters of patients.
We do know that there's high concordance between driver events within the
primary tumor and with
tumor DNA detected within plasma.
And while quantitative measures of ctDNA at baseline do seem to
associate with tumor bulk, they don't consistently predict outcome
alone.
What about in the postoperative setting for virus-unrelated head and neck cancer?
There's been a number of efforts to try and optimize and predict detection in
the early surgical phase. This is data on the left from Dan
Fain's lab, again, deploying what he calls
maestro, a highly sensitive assay,
which uses whole genome tumor-informed and mutation enrichment
sequencing assay in a pooled testing format with
really excellent performance characteristics.
Although even in that setting, multiple time points in the early
post-op setting may be more predictive for recurrence.
And this is on the right side, another very, I think, interesting and
innovative approach of trying to leverage the
post-surgical lymphatic drain fluid that's in place for most
patients after head and neck surgery, and able to identify, using a
tumor-informed ctDNA detection, that at least in the intermediate
pathologic risk, seems to be able to predict local regional recurrence.
Again, as you'd expect, be able to predict that pattern of recurrence, again, in
patients with looking at the tumor drain fluid.
Again, there's been multiple assays that have been able to effectively detect MRD
in the surveillance post-treatment setting. Here's an example of two of these.
Again, on the left, a tumor-informed radar assay.
On the right, a genome-wide methylation-based assay.
Again, clearly this is where there's a strong signal, particularly when there's
multiple time points rather than just a single landmark time point.
And then in the recurrent metastatic setting, here we've learned quite a bit
about how early ctDNA dynamics may be able
to inform which patients are benefiting from
immunotherapy-based treatment.
In that first column, you can see this is data from the INSPIRE trial showing,
using a tumor-informed assay, that dynamics after two
cycles of immunotherapy predicts response, and this has now also been
validated with the same clinical data set
with a tissue-agnostic methylomic-based assay.
Clearance by six to eight weeks seems to be important in terms of predicting
progression-free survival. And how early, again, can these kinetics be helpful?
Well, it seems that even after one cycle or even after one week,
now with some data that came out this
year, may be able to predict which patients are the ones that
are going to benefit from immunotherapy.
We tried to leverage this and test this in a prospective
trial at our institution and within our
network sites called the SYNERGY trial.
It was a trial that enrolled recurrent metastatic head and neck cancer patients.
Initial treatment stratified by PD-L1, so the high PD-L1 expressers
started pembrolizumab alone, and then either continued pembro or
escalated to pembro plus chemo if the ctDNA was
uptrending. Whereas low PD-L1 expressers started treatment with
pembro plus chemo, and if ctDNA decreased after two cycles,
were de-escalated to pembro alone.
Whereas if it was increasing, they continued chemo plus pembro with
adaptive treatment every two cycles, and the primary response
endpoint in this trial.
We observed an objective response rate of 63%.
Again, high response rates across both PD-L1
stratified initial treatment arms.
And again, we saw progression-free survival 6.4 months and median overall
survival of 30.9 months with this ctDNA response
adaptive approach.And then just in terms of treatment
exposure, we did identify that about three-quarters of patients at
some point could be deescalated based on ctDNA adaptive
decision-making with a median number of chemotherapy cycles of
only two. And just to look at this
swimmers plot here, you can just appreciate how some patients had
ctDNA dynamics that lent themselves to either immunotherapy
alone or really minimal chemotherapy, while other patients had ctDNA
dynamics that really warranted, in this protocol,
rapid
succession of all six cycles of chemoimmunotherapy quite quickly
and then progressed. So again, highlighting the fact that kinetics over
time may really differentiate the biology and therapeutic
responsiveness. Oh, here's an example of one of these
patients that we treated, HPV positive head and neck cancer patient who recurred
two years later with a lung metastasis.
Again, biopsy showed low PD-L1 expression, and this patient started
chemo pembro on the study. Again, despite the fact that the initial CT
showed stable disease, the ctDNA rapidly cleared.
This patient was deescalated to pembro alone, and over time, not only cleared their
ctDNA, but also had what ended up being quite a durable,
complete response.
We also saw data at this meeting from the Meridian trial that was presented by Dr.
Sanz-Garcia. Again, the group should be commended for having done this
trial, where they checked MRD after definitive treatment, and MRD
positive patients were randomized to PD-1 TIGIT versus
observation. And again, although only one patient ended up
receiving the immunotherapeutic strategy, I think it is notable that this
patient did clear their ctDNA and didn't recur, whereas for
the untreated patients, the positive predictive value and specificity
was 100%. So again, an early signal about potential
early interception, despite the fact that this is only one patient.
So where does this take us into future directions in terms of therapeutic drug
development? I think that we're moving towards a space where in a future
state, we could imagine using ctDNA multi-omic
real-time clonal data to rapidly assess
multiple novel therapeutics in a much more rapid fashion than we're currently able
to do with our current modalities, and really trying to integrate these into
drug development, into dosing optimization.
Obviously, we need multi-center harmonization, and then randomized data will
ultimately be needed. So just to conclude, MRD is emerging as a
promising biomarker to guide treatment optimization in head and neck cancer across
therapeutic settings.
Both escalation and de-escalation strategies are being developed across both
subtypes of head and neck cancer. And really what we need to do is continue to
further improve our biomarker optimization, as well as improving
therapeutics as well. So with that, thanks for your attention and thanks for the
invitation.
So we do have time for some questions.
And again, I'll ask you to please come up to the microphone if
you have a question so that the people online can hear.
Maybe I'll start.
The appeal, I guess, of the methylation-based assays
that don't need to be tumor-informed, it sounds like
that's not the way your group really went, and I wonder what your thinking was.
Yeah. I
would say,
I think both are worth testing. I actually agree with
you that the fact that it's tumor agnostic is very appealing.
At our center, as like yours, many of these patients are treated
non-surgically. Oftentimes, there's not enough tumor to develop.
And I didn't show the slide, but in the synergy trial, there were some
non-evaluable patients because there was inadequate tumor tissue to generate a
personalized assay. So the deployment in the clinic is greatly impacted by the
clinical availability of tumor tissue.
And so I think we need to continue exploring both strategies.
I think tumor agnostic approaches, if they can
reach the same sensitivity and
technical aspects as tumor-informed, that would be a phenomenal advance for the
field. But I think as of right now, that tumor-informed advantage, at least for
patients that have adequate tissue, seems to have unique advantages in
terms of the ultra-sensitivity and being able to detect those earliers
would then allow us to intervene earlier with therapeutic
interventions. So I'm a fan of exploring both.
When we developed this study, we only had immunotherapy
response data for tumor-informed, which is why
we used that, because that was the data we had at the time.
But I think at this point, either could be used.
I guess we all end up in the dilemma sometimes where we see
circulating tumor DNA increasing, and we
don't really
know exactly what to do at this point.
I'm just wondering, do you
foresee a time where
there's enough correlation with this marker with ultimate
outcome that we can start treating?
And then how do we determine what to treat with?
Yeah, it's a great question.
So I would argue in the post-treatment setting, if that's happening and there's no
evidence of disease, they should enroll in the study.
Which is going to be open at your site and our site.
And no, I think the best thing is for us to try to test that
prospectively, in the context of clinical trials, so we can
demonstrate the benefit.
I think one of the challenges that you alluded to, right, is some of these
patients have gross disease and then can follow the
pathway to immunotherapy-based treatment from
048 and for other trials that are enrolling in that setting.
But I think that these should be tested in the context of trials.
Okay. I don't see any questions online, so if there's nothing else, we can
wrap up the session. Thank you both for wonderful talks, and thank you to the
audience for coming. And enjoy the rest of the meeting. Bye-bye.